nets the takeaway
allen to lynn to laberd going upstairs
for the two-handed flush
and that one i would put in the on the
one to ten ten being the severe
that would be probably a one or a two
because it wasn't that severe but he's
around the neck
here's levert the cross over the drive
the way for karis leverk
rozier
here's levert the drive in it's good
and one
[Music]
check by paul screen from booker levert
goes around it
drive kick harrison open look splash
it's a triple he's in business
49-34 houston up towards the rim
contact no call and laverth gets the
deuce
last shot here for the nets out of the
timeout levert using the allen screen
the floater it goes for levert and he
beats the buzzer
goes down nets are five on four here
after the porter miss
levert lines it up and buries it it's a
triple for charis liberty
but they are playing much better and
they almost turned it over now buddy
looking for an easy shot here's hill
and he'll carry the ball net
mason little hesitation blocked by
laverg nine seconds on the shot clock
dan winnie not that time
ziller the fight on the offensive glass
he finds levert
you bet plus the foul karis laverne
clears it for levert nine to shoot
swing it for ac step back three bottom
put up and pile up their points olmer
ashik
is in now for new orleans leverk
gets to the rim paris lavert the assist
to diallo
25 dishes
[Applause]
laverne is fouled charis laverge
minute mark of this second quarter
gordon backdoor
intercepted levert steps in front of 48.
he is quick defensively levert
gives it up hollis jefferson to follow
levert sticks with a play
lavert looking for okafor will take it
himself play it in
plus the foul ending by morris not that
he didn't draw just one or two guys in
his direction three guys went his way
but bert pounds it down after a quick
first step
job of getting into the paint by divert
julius will bring it up as he
likes to do good food
no good levert two seconds revert to the
rim
circus shot charis leverk beats the
buzzer
and we hit the break in brooklyn
valentine streaking to the rim levert a
factor
russell oh perfect feed joe harris
finishes
no good on a three ball but that's half
time four seconds
three seconds two seconds levert the
pull-up pop
he's got it charis levert
we go to the fourth in a tight one who i
think
d'angelo may be a little too high risk
for his liking
and then spencer did when he on the
other hand maybe more low risk
lavert gets it back and puts it in
before
time expires
robert looking to shake embiid slides
around him and lays it in
what a nifty finish from charis laverne
10 00 next run
witty operating for brooklyn with laverg
who hits another three jefferson
gives it up two to shoot levert storms
in
beats the clock and puts it home his
ability to get past that first line
five seconds stutter step
levert spin fade at the horn
karis levert beats the buzzer
one to shoot gets it off does he get the
roll he does
and a big one for brooklyn as that will
end the third quarter
tied up by wade lost the ball the chase
is on it's winslow
blocked by levert taken by
jefferson saves it in the crab tony
that's one of the best hustle plays i've
seen all year from a player
nobody there to scoop that up with
holmes from a nice play by okafor
upstairs levert
the scouting report is give him the shot
know your personnel
allen turned around i think before he
released it a three
and the nets have set a new franchise
record
15 straight games with at least ten
three pointers made
hard to believe i don't know if they're
just reading our graphics
scooped up by cunningham up ahead for
dinwiddie he's got lebert love it up
slam karis laverne on a special delivery
[Applause]
reverse with a drive gets to the rack
scoops and scores levert one on one with
hardaway
nets looking for the win levert makes
his move drives in
fake shot is good one second left
the nets go in front by two attacking
defense from the pacers
shot clock is down to four levert will
take
and hit well they'll take that three
i had a conversation with jared uh
before the game
the slam by allen what a setup by levert
he draws nance levert shimmy
spin pivot [ __ ] karis levert
big time highlight defensively there's
been plenty of movement
off the ball as well spencer dinwiddie
in back door
love vert love jam and a foul
the coogie look tied at 18.
marquise chris in for houston oh lavert
the dribble drive then settled in
in the san diego area eventually here in
arizona
the flush carris laverne on a cut to the
rim
and jared allen with a perfect feed all
eight of the nets points
have come in the paint lever trying to
tack on two more he does
great job just going at the big
fellowship both down you're gonna be all
right
shot puck winding down levert has to
make it happen straight away love
verge touch from the outside
rebounding getting second chance
opportunities another possession
an important emphasis for the nets here
tonight no look inside to jared allen
great feed by charis laver
forced now to make a move down to four
losing a lot of time lever gave a glance
for the win
yes karis laverne
there's point three on the clock first
five games they were last with over 19.
seven to shoot russell great look and
levert
throws it down felicio the offensive
board
and a reload for chicago cut by harrison
lost the ball
levert takes it away
levert surveys carroll fires got it
with three seconds walker is gonna have
to hoist
walker stripped by robert do they call a
foul
they do not game over brooklyn
wins it 117 115
the final bridges gives it up
williams on the drive feeding it off to
zeller rejected by levert outbound
excellent job protecting the wreck had
that knee injury that he suffered in
this
late in his career at florida recovered
from that was perfect
oh from deep
[Applause]
222 to go it comes right at me it didn't
go that way did it
levert turns the corner on jones oh
love vertical and the foul
because conditioning and rhythm are real
concerns from him
he says biking's not the same on all
things in practice
he is not going and doing much they are
very focused on joel embiid's eating
and diet as
final two well here comes levert to the
wreck
and a tough floater in traffic to take
us to the end of the first quarter
i'm excited bird it is exciting the lob
allen had to redirect finds laverne
underneath for the uncontested flush
too strong rebound ends up with revert
looking to push prince ahead of the
field great fine
levert to prince for two
that's just four of 17 from deep thus
far as levert
finally gets one to drop allen levert
allen temple
carrots and dinwiddie the five for
brooklyn levert
fading away oh yeah
[Applause]
as levert can't squeeze that in allen
denied at the rim
and another chance for brooklyn good cut
from harris he finds out who lays it in
as the nets jump in front their first
lead of the game
they averaged just 12 a game levert
separates hands hits oh
that looks smooth no rust
he now has 20 points and eight assists
for the game levert
his turn bucket
three to shoot harris three
it's something though the nets have been
able to take advantage of with their
pick and roll
oh charis laverne that is wet
it's only because i love you good hands
and then gets back to it
what an effort from laverne who lays it
in five seconds
levert three seconds levert at the horn
got it karis laverg
beats the buzzer at the end of the first
[Music]
[Applause]
shoot got a launch hits the three
and he got fouled by boucher
[Applause]
two-point shot just shy of three-point
range
he thought he was to bounce it and slam
but he lost it
but so did gord levert had six steals
the other night
temple kick tlc a three levert will take
and hit before a fading shot clock
expires
celtics is an english word you don't
combine it with if you want to be
the celtics fine or you're going to be
spanish you're going to be los celticos
as chris chioza knocks down the j and i
like that he was aggressive out of the
gates he was 2-9
from the field we got some
aggressiveness on the defensive end too
mitchell now with a six-point game
taking only three shots thurl
a couple of assists
a 9-0 magic run levert
will get it off and hit
at the buzzer karis levert ends the 9-0
run
here in the second
they go inside to brown nice catch block
from behind
good recovery from levert 6.9 on the
clock kerosene almost slips see if the
next can get a look
nice crossover kerins gets it to go at
the buzzer
and that should count and karis levert
and the nets will take the lead into the
second quarter the question will be
about how much
and it's a lot count that basket and
you look at the blazers team very
different as you mentioned that we saw
back in november
levert hits the mid-range and that's
something we've seen
as he was going back on d we'll keep
track of that levert
off a 24 point game the other night and
he gives off to jared allen
rebounded by anna nobody he'll take it
strong can't score
karis levert lines it up bottom
six nothing lead leverk from downtown
see if the nets can continue this sweet
offensive start levert off the handoff
from allen
here he comes slithering into the paid
off balance and he's headed to the
free-throw line
speaking about that with former
sacramento kings star doug christie
recently says it's not unusual
as lebert slams one home he says he
entered pepperdine
as a 19 year old
51 shooting had three 20-point games in
the eight seating games for brooklyn
knock away and the grizzlies turned it
over levert
deals harris
and joe harris brings the bell from
three again
leverk two defenders there brooks gets a
piece
down to one second at the horn lever
connects
the nets go to the break up by one
early season promise under doc rivers
levert step back three
he's got it if i'm dr rivers i really
like the shots that
we're getting from the three-point line
to danny green and others they've been
good shots pacing shots and how about
that
leverk he floats a little bit in the air
working around the perimeter for levert
rolling to the rim jared allen the throw
flush
passes him open